there have been many brilliant minds who
have lent their talents the committing
and the solving of crime but none stands
as supremely as that of Sherlock Holmes
with his unequaled powers of reasoning
deduction and scientific application
Holmes was able to solve the cases that
baffled the best of Scotland Yard with
his tweed suit cloth cap and his black
clay pipe the world's greatest sleuth
has become familiar to a new generation
through television and movie adaptations
of his many adventures in this week's by
graphics we have dug deep to uncover the
private world of the notoriously
secretive mr. Holmes Sherlock Holmes may
well have been the greatest detective
living or dead to investigate the
criminal minds but he was an extremely
private genius as a result of the study
of his early years is an exercise in
frustration for biographers on one of
the few occasions that he did open up
about his family origins he mentioned to
his ever loyal sidekick James Watson
that his ancestors were country Squires
who appear to have led much the same
life as his natural to people of their
class he also revealed that his
grandmother was the sister of MLG Norris
Vernay the renowned French artist who
specialized in military paintings his
final familial revelation was that he
had an older brother Mycroft who
according to Sherlock himself possessed
even greater powers of deduction than he
did apart from those few tidbits we are
left to work out the details of Holmes's
early life from circumstantial evidence
and deduction something of a coincidence
I might think Holmes was born and raised
in the county of Sussex on the south
coast of England the Holmes family seat
was at slim-fit a few miles from Horsham
Sherlock's father gentleman named
Roderick Holmes was born around 1815
Roderick was a man's man who delighted
in such outdoor pursuits as fox hunting
trout fishing and pheasant shooting in
sharp contrast to his two sons he didn't
put much credence in book-learning and
affairs of the mines
Sherlock's mother was 13 years younger
than her husband's Charlotte hair Croft
came from language
origins were French from her mother's
the silver neighs she inherited not only
artistic leanings but a flighty
self-absorbed personality the marriage
it was not a happy one with such
disparate personalities it could be said
that it was doomed from the start
their first child was born in 1846 and
given the name of John Mycroft Holmes
the name gives us an insight into the
state of the parents mental processes
Roderick hated his own name and wanted
to give his firstborn son a plain
uncomplicated name but Charlotte had
quite the opposite view she wanted a
name that was different striking and
memorable of course Roderick one that
Charlotte managed to squeeze her choice
an amalgam of her possessive nature my
with the last syllable of her maiden
name Croft in as a middle name it was
only because he spends more of his
formative years around his possessive
mother that the boy came to be known as
Mycroft a name which grated on his
father every time he heard it
it took Roderick and Charlotte seven
years to produce another child no
surprise considering the deteriorating
state of their union by now Roderick had
given up entirely on trying to control
his wife's artistic or as he saw it
irrational sight he left an ending up to
her and she even outdid her creativity
the first time around she named a second
son Sherlock the name wasn't entirely
her own invention in order to escape
from the increasing abuse of her
husband's who had taken more and more to
the bottle she began making trips to
London where she would visit art
galleries and theatre performances she
became enamored with a father-and-son
pair of English artists both who were
named William Sherlock in the hopes that
her second would prove to be a great
artist she gave him the moniker Sherlock
there was the custom of the day to send
sons away to boarding school Roderick
didn't believe in higher education and
so the two brothers endured a succession
of tutors some of whom were good while
others were terrible even when they did
have a good teacher the now volatile
environment caused by the parents
loathing for one another did not make
for conductive learning however Mycroft
and Sherlock educated themselves despite
their environments it soon became
apparent that both boys were brilliant
Sherlock instantly fell in love with
books later referring to himself as an
omnivorous reader his brother meanwhile
was obsessed with numbers even though
there was a 7-year gap in age the two
boys were extraordinarily close they
drew up on each other for mutual support
and mental stimulation
Mycroft grew into an overweight child
who avoided any type of exercise or
physical exertion instead in his early
teens he became fascinated with
electricity and chemistry this soon
caught the attention of his younger
brother he began saving his pocket money
to buy scientific apparatus Sherlock
escapes the unpleasant environment at
home by finding interests outside the
house
he developed a friendship with man who
was in charge of his father's hunting
house this man named Sherman was a
taxidermist and Sherlock spent many
hours watching him at work the boy also
spent a lot of time and his father's
stables where a develops a great equine
knowledge unlike his brother
Sherlock enjoyed sports he became a
talented young boxer winning a number of
matches against local boys Roderick
during his sober periods tried his best
to turn the boys into country Squires
though they both became possible shots
with fouling thisis neither of them had
any stomach for fox hunting furthermore
Mycroft was a poor horse rider one
consolation for Roderick though was that
they both took to fishing what they
really relished was the quiet
contemplative nature of the activity
which provided plenty of time for
planning overall however Roderick was
disappointed in how his sons were
turning out I'm surprisingly then he
very rarely showed them any affection
preferring to cast aspirations on their
manhood and their physical prowess is
like a physical display was more than
compensated for by Charlotte who would
shower the boys with hugs and kisses at
every opportunity
this only served to further strengthen
Roderick's conviction that he had raised
a couple of sissies when her sons were
old enough
took them to London where she introduced
them to concerts and opera and guided
them through the picture galleries of
the metropolis the brothers found her
chatter tiresome and her behavior
sometimes embarrassing but they were
grateful to get away from their father
as a result of these London visits
Sherlock developed a strong love of
music this inspired Charlotte to hire
violin teacher for the boy but the
lessons they didn't last long
when Roderick found out about it he put
an immediate stop to the lessons Mycroft
and Sherlock also didn't spend a lot of
time with other boys in the community
they found not to be up to their
intellectual level and so spent most of
their time together however they did
make one great friends and that would be
Charles Edward Howard Vincent's Charles
was the son of Sir Frederick Vincent's
rector of the parish of slim-fit this
boy was just as brilliant as the Holmes
boys he was sent off to boarding school
his aged 12 spends most of his time
during the school vacations in the
company of Mycroft and Sherlock Charles
Howard Vincent went on to forge a
distinguished multifaceted career which
fills two pages in Britain's Dictionary
of National Biography Roderick refused
to send his oldest son to university
when Mycroft reached the age of 20 but
by now the older brother had enough of
his father's abusive ways and he moved
to London where he secured a position as
an assistant to a member of parliament
when his brother moved away Sherlock was
13 years of age he spent an unhappy few
years as a loner in the land happy
household
his only bright spots being the regular
letters that he received from his
brother in London unsurprisingly at age
18 Sherlock convinced his father to send
him to Cambridge University during his
first semester he was invited by a
fellow students by the name of Victor
Trevor to spend the vacation with him
that his family's estate in Norfolk not
games he returned to his feuding parents
he gladly accepted the invitation
following this visit Sherlock did not
return home for future holidays that
took rooms in London where he buried
himself in chemical research he had his
mind set on becoming a chemical analyst
while the University Holmes played no
part in team sports which would have
required cooperation with others instead
he focused on boxing the only friends he
had at college was Victor Trevor just as
the only friends he had as an adult was
dr. Watson
in the autumn of 1874 Sherlock began his
third year of study at Cambridge but he
left before the year was out with no
degree the details have never been
revealed but it is clear that some sort
of trauma afflicted both sherlock and
mycroft during these months and left
psychological wounds on both of them
biographers have speculated that the
situation may have involved members of
the opposite sex dr. Watson later sheds
some light on the Holmes mindset his
aversion to women and his disinclination
to form new friendships were both
typical of his unemotional character but
not more so than his complete
suppression of every reference to his
own people Holmes himself once said I am
NOT a whole sould admirer of womankind
women are never to be entirely trusted
not the best of them
despite this Holmes was always courteous
and considerate to women his hostility
to the other sex was confined to the
areas of love and marriage
so whatever the precise nature of this
emotional blow it resulted in Sherlock
being a lifelong user of narcotics this
addiction was in sharp contrast to his
temperance and otherwise clean mode of
living at the time the use of narcotics
in Britain was legal
still the habit was alarming to dr.
Watson who on more than one occasion
tried to reason with the great detective
that it was a mind destroying completely
wasteful and in vertical practice homes
usually brushed him off about it over
the years but with Watson's help he was
able to have limited success in shaking
off the habit whether the tragic events
was separate to the death of Holmes's
parents is not clear those passings
surely would have been horrific in
themselves they occurred in the autumn
of 1874 when Mycroft was in London and
Sherlock at Cambridge on hearing the
news both boys returned immediately to
Sussex their father had been killed by a
pistol shot of the head while their
mother had been strangled the police
immediately ruled out murder-suicide but
Mycroft and Sherlock knew better
they lonely and depressed Charlotte had
found release in the arms of another man
on discovering the affair
Roderick had strangled his wife in a
frenzy and then staggered to the stables
where he had turned the pistol on
himself the two sons deduced all of this
from a careful examination of the scene
coupled with their insider knowledge of
the state of their parents marriage the
man who had been the subject of
Charlotte's affection and therefore the
indirect
the tragedy was a man of privilege by
the name of law a plankton he discreetly
left the area after the deaths but his
actions left a deep-seated resentment of
titles men in the heart of Sherlock his
family tragedy his Holmes at the age of
20 they left him with a deep-seated
bitterness against his mother apart from
his brother she was the only person who
had ever shown him love and affection
and from all of this what he decided he
needed was a complete change of scenery
from earliest boyhood Sherlock had been
fascinated with the American West he
wanted to travel to America and pay his
way for some time so Mycroft advanced
him some money from his father's estate
he left for the New World in early 1875
when he arrived in New York he became
fascinated by the theater scene in
Manhattan it provided the escape that he
needed in fact he loved the scene so
much that he drifted into a theatrical
troupe in the autumn of 1875 because
Victorian society in America as well as
in England considered acting at less
than reputable occupation Holmes chose
not to tarnish his family name by
calling himself mr. Sherlock
after a brief run in in Manhattan the
troupe went on tour lands that took them
as far as Chicago though his career on
the American stage lasted for less than
a year Holmes found the work absorbing
and soon became adept at the
professional skills of makeup in
disguise
this ability benefited him greatly in
later cases where he recreated himself
into everything from an Italian priest
to an old woman
to obtain realistic details for the
working class and criminal roles he
played on stage Homs ventured into
dangerous neighborhoods in New York and
other cities that is true visitors this
often proved hazardous requiring the
cooperation of the local police these
excursions also gave Homs contacts and
information that he was able to draw on
during his later professional career as
he followed police investigations in the
cities he was touring he began to
realize the practical value of the
scientific knowledge he had games from
his boyhood experiments and his
Cambridge education blood stains poisons
mud caked on shoes liquid left in
glasses his scientific way of looking at
such clues revealed forensic evidence
which he was able to pass on to the
police for the first time he began to
seriously consider taking up detective
work professionally he imagined himself
something entirely new to the Victorian
era a scientific detective this motive
was to power him through the rest of his
life after 18 months of travelling
around the United States
Holmes decided it was time to return to
the country of his birth on return to
London he found lodging just around the
corner from British Museum he began
running errands for private detectives
carrying out such distasteful duties as
gathering evidence for divorce cases but
all the while he was picking up the
basics of detective work to further this
work he revived his study of science
with a focus on chemistry botany and
Anatomy after a year or so Holmes was
ready to branch off and start his own
detective agency his first cases were
domestic and routine revolving around -
civil disputes he worked hard to
cultivate his relationship with the
police passing on information that would
help them crack a case in return the
police passed clients on to him the year
1888 was a fortunate one for Sherlock
Holmes a scandal had left the London
police in a situation than they were
open to the up-and-coming detective the
case which has become known as the
Musgrave ritual was his first
high-profile case establishing his
superior powers of deduction and Foresta
investigation to a fascinated public the
case got underway when Holmes was called
by a university acquaintance Reginald
Musgrave two of Musgraves domestic staff
had disappeared following their
dismissal for reading a secret family
documents called the Musgrave ritual
Holmes not only solved the case but
uncovered
crown of King Charles the first which
had been missing for 200 years as a
result of the fame garnered from the
Musgrave ritual Holmes was invited to
give a series of lectures to instruct
the newly formed Criminal Investigation
Department or CID the brilliant 24 year
old now found himself enlightening
hard-bitten career cops on Anatomy
chemistry and botany he also at this
point you enough about geology to
identify soil on clothing and shoes more
and more detectives now got into the
habit of consulting with Holmes when
they reached an impasse in their
investigations even though they hated to
admit it
the young PI would invariably provide
them with the breakthrough that they
needed in order to crack a case in 1881
Holmes began lodging with the man who
would become inextricably tied to
himself dr. John Watson the address was
2 to 1 B Baker Street
Watson was a young medic who had just
returned from Afghanistan and was
looking for a cheap place to live on the
first meeting Watson was fascinated that
Holmes deduced that he had recently been
in Afghanistan without him having
proffered that information from that
moment on Watson was hooked his part
Holmes seemed delighted to share his
home with the affable dr. Watson the two
men would go on to form a partnership
that has been unequaled in the annals of
Criminal Investigation as Holmes his
reputation grew he attracted more and
more affluent clients and was able to
charge higher fees these - subsidised
others in which he helps people who
could only pay a small fee or no fee at
all he once said that the status of my
client is of less interest to me than
the interest of his case what he was
after were cases that challenged him
his greatest challenge came in his
ongoing hunt for London's master
criminal Professor Moriarty in order to
avoid Moriarty's criminal organisation
Holmes was forced to flee Europe in late
1891 but the criminal mastermind pursued
the great detective and a climactic
struggle occurred top theory can mark
falls in Switzerland it appears that
both men fall to their death and the
funeral is held for the world's greatest
detective however Holmes's body was
never recovered
and indeed he was not dead for three
years though he allowed the world
including dr. Watson to believe that he
was dead this period is known by
biographers as the Krait hiatus in 1894
he was suddenly back on the scene
explaining to a bewildered dr. Watson
that he had faked his death to get
Moriarty his henchmen off his back 10
years later Holmes retired to a small
farm in Sussex Downs where he took up
beekeeping in 1908 he came out of
retirement in order to aid his
government's working as a double agents
he masterminded the capture of a German
spy
it is believed he kept busy with
intelligence work during the First World
War there is no record of Holmes's
activities after the war so when did
Sherlock Holmes die the answer is
obvious just consider the plethora of TV
shows movies and books on the man and he
will surely agree that Sherlock Holmes
had never died just as he had never
lived Sherlock Holmes he's a complete
work of fiction the creation of a writer
by the name of Arthur Conan Doyle but if
you've spent the last 20 minutes
believing that you were learning the
history of a real-life human being
you're certainly not alone in a recent
poll 21 percent of respondents thought
that the great sleuth of Baker Street
really did exist which just goes to show
that sometimes fiction is stranger than
truth lands you might notice that this
video was published on April the 1st
happy April Fool's to everybody so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic if you did there's a couple
of things you could do right now one is
hit that like button below also if you
want more stuff like this we put out
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
or something else right now stuff from
the archive over there on the right and
as always thank you for watching